hey everyone in cereth registered nurse  RN comm and in this video i'm going to  demonstrate how to emulate with a walker  to ambulate with the walker first the  patient's going to get in position and  hold onto the hand grips of the walker  first they will lift and move the walker  forward and then make sure all four  points of the walker are touching the  ground then they will move the weakside  put weight on the hands via the hand  grips and then move the strong side  again they will lift the Walker move it  forward make sure all four points are on  the ground then they will move the weak  side put weight on the handgrips and  then move the strong side  you  thank you so much for watching and don't  forget to subscribe to our channel for  more videos